it only took seconds for an end of term
party to turn to utter tragedy just
before 10 this morning a Land Rover
plowed across the grass into a building
at the study prep school a private all
girls Primary in Wimbledon common
police the fire brigade ambulance Crews
and even the air ambulance all raced to
the scene
16 people were hurt and one little girl
lost her life
our officers along with colleagues from
other Emergency Services provided first
aid to a number of people who had been
injured
very sadly one of the children an
eight-year-old girl tired of the scene
our thoughts are with her family at this
incredibly difficult time
an appalling end to the year at a quiet
much-loved School
a young child on the last day of term
celebrating the end of term with friends
it was also tragic in the impact it's
going to have on a huge number of other
young children and family and friends
across the community very much a
Wimbledon school so lots of Wimbledon
families will have children or had had
children here indeed many years ago my
own daughter went here and it's built a
sense of community not with only within
the school but in the wider Wimbledon
area and so the effect tonight will be
felt very deeply
as the tow truck arrives to take the
Land Rover away we know the police are
continuing to scour the area for
evidence and to try and work out what
happened here as all day we've seen
injured and traumatized schoolgirls
being led away from the school holding
tights onto the hands of their shaken
parents this has horrified an entire
tight-knit community
I mean I'm just shaking I can't believe
this has happened like five minutes down
where I live
and I just understand why it's
and children of all people as well
in a statement the schools say it is
still far too soon to fully understand
what happened but we are well aware of
these significant impact this Dreadful
event will have on our pupils and their
families their welfare remains our top
priority and we will be doing everything
we can to support them especially those
who suffered injuries
police were quick to say they weren't
treating this as Terror related and a
woman in her 40s has been arrested on
suspicion of causing death by dangerous
driving
now a school Community must come to
terms with what happened here
the family face the unimaginable loss of
their eight-year-old daughter
Rachel Venable's Sky News Wimbledon